When we initialized to this computer's
turn variable using the default in that
method we never actually set
its move property to anything.
We need to fill in our generate
move method in order to randomly
generate a move for the computer.
The best tool for
this job is a switch statement.
The syntax for switch statements in
Objective-C take this general form.
Switch statements in Objective-C
are quite limited compared to Swift and
that they can only condition
upon the value of an integer.
They also differ in that the flow
of control falls through.
That means you need to include a break
statement following the statement to be
executed for each case.
It's also required that you
include a default case.
Now let's apply this to
our generateMove method.
To generate a random move for
the computer, we'll first need
a random integer between zero and two.
We'll get that using this line of code,
using the familiar arc4random method.
Now on to our switch statement.
Will switch on the value of
the interger we just generated and
return a different move for each case.
Note the break statements
after each case.
We're going to need a default case
to catch any invalid numbers.
But right now our enum just
has three expected choices.
Let's add a case for invalid to our
enum, and then we can return that for
our default case.
Now we have a catch-all in the event
that we get some number that's not
between 0 and 2.
We check that we have a break statement
after the default case, and that's it.
Our generateMove method is ready to go.